nous sommes avec valérie boyer sénatrice
la république à des bouches du rhône
valérie boyer
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors étant le coprésident du
groupe de minsk
la france ne doit-elle pas garder son
statut de neutralité pour permettre au
fond la résolution du conflit
hélas d'abord merci de m'interroger sur
cette question qui est éminemment
importante
et si vous me le permettez elle est
importante videmment pour le sud caucase
mais elle est importante aussi pour la
france elle est importante pour l'europe
parce que faire sauter le verrou du haut
karabagh puis après celui de l'armée a
ni c'est sûr que rien n'arrêtera la
turquie qui déjà jette des bases à
chypre dans les îles grecques puisque je
rappelle que cet été la turquie a
survolé a violé l'espace aérien et
l'espace maritime grecque sans qu'il y
ait vraiment eu de réaction ni de
sanctions et des réactions courageuse de
la france et de la grèce mais il n'y a
pas eu de sanction derrière dont c'est
extrêmement important
y compris j'allais dire pour notre unité
nationale et y compris face à la menace
terroriste qui malheureusement en deuil
la france alors à votre question doit-on
rester neutres ben je dirais des
semaines tout te disais que être neutre
c'est choisir son camp et est ce que la
france est ce que l'europe peuvent
choisir le camp de la barbarie est ce
que la france est ce que l'europe
tolérer qu'il y ait encore haut karabagh
qu'il y ait encore pour les arméniens du
haut-karabakh et d'arménie à nouveau
génocide
je rappelle que l'azerbaïdjan à attaquer
le haut karabagh et a attaqué également
l'arménie qui est un état souverain donc
on est bien dans une déclaration de
guerre totalement asymétrique et qui n'a
qu'une seule visée exterminer éradiquer
la population arménienne faire du
nettoyage ethnique et un nettoyage
culturel parce qu'on sait que
malheureusement
en plus de tuer des humains
l'azerbaïdjan et ça et d'effacer toutes
les traces de la présence arménienne qui
est pourtant ancestrale qui est qui date
de plusieurs siècles sur ce territoire
qui a toujours était arménien alors
début octobre jean yves le drian s'était
positionné en faveur de cette neutralité
la position du gouvernement est ce qu
elle peut évoluer selon vous cette
neutralité elle n'est ni responsable ni
digne et surtout elle est totalement
inefficace
on n'en est pas à la neutralité on en
est aux massacres de populations civiles
je rappelle quand même que le
haut-karabakh c'est à peu près
l'équivalent de la ville de nice et que
l'arménie c'est deux millions deux
millions et demi d'habitants donc on est
que le budget militaire de l'azerbaïdjan
il est largement supérieure au budget
total de l'arménie et que l'azerbaïdjan
en l'occurrence est le bras armé de la
turquie dans cette affaire et que se
passe-t-il
ça fait des mois et des mois que
monsieur erdogan pour masquer ses échecs
intérieurs ses échecs économiques et
même politiques et surtout après le coup
d'état de 2016
essaye de se trouver une issue
international sa à commencer par la
libye et puis ensuite il ya eu les a
chip ou à chypre où il avance des pions
quand même chypre est un étal l'union
européenne il avance des pions sans que
rien ne se passe ça a commencé aussi ça
continue avec les menaces vis-à-vis des
grecs le massacre au kurdistan
l'attitude plus qu'envie ballan devoir
dire complice avec les djihadistes lors
de la guerre de syrie et là nous avons
de véritables attaques avec des
djihadistes d'ailleurs
qui qui sont lâchés contre les
populations arméniennes
donc on voit bien les intentions
absolument belliqueuse de la turquie et
de l'azerbaïdjan parce que l'un ne va
pas sans l'autre l'un agit pour le
compte de l'autre vis-à-vis de l'arménie
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui recep
tayyip erdogan et imanaliev certes
souhaite s'offrir en trophée le
haut-karabakh puis l'arménie dont très
nette de toute façon pour vous au jeu
malheureusement ils n'ont jamais caché
leurs intentions ils le disent de façon
tout à fait clair et je rappelle quand
même que ceux qui s'intéressent à cette
question hante en mémoire les pogroms
anti-arméniens des années 1990
donc pour vous aujourd'hui la france
veut clairement se dresser aujourd'hui
pour vous la france doit clairement se
dresser devant l' influence grandissante
de la turquie
par quelle voie par voie diplomatique
je pense qu'il ya plusieurs voies la
première c'est la voie diplomatique et
il est urgent de reconnaître l'état
indépendant d'arc ça ça fait 30 ans que
les accords de mix piétine et il faut le
faire en urgence pourquoi parce que
seule la reconnaissance d'un état
indépendant ce qui glay dans les faits
depuis 30 ans parce que c'est une
démocratie en plus il ya permettrait de
protéger ces populations
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est également d'envoyer des
troupes internationales au sol sous
mandat de l'onu
on ne peut pas laisser cette population
est totalement massacré et c'est ce qui
est en train de se passer
je rappelle quand même que l'azerbaïdjan
utilisent des armes non conventionnelles
vis-à-vis de populations civiles qui
sont déjà dans un dénuement important et
là c'est encore plus ils visent des
églises ils vivent des hôpitaux ils
disent des écoles il envoie quand même
des barbares djihadistes contre ses
populations
donc on est dans une urgence humanitaire
et se taire c'est peut-être du côté des
barbares et aujourd'hui je pense que la
france ne peut pas l'être
la france ne peut pas l'être parce que
c'est son devoir historique de d'abord
d'aider les peuples qui veulent disposer
d'eux mêmes c'est le cas des arméniens
du haut karabagh c'est aussi son devoir
de mémoire vis-à-vis des rescapés du
génocide de 1915 perpétré par les turcs
qui ont trouvé refuge en france comme
dans plein de pays dans plein de pays au
monde mais en france puisque nous sommes
en france et que nous en parlons c'est
son devoir parce qu'elle est membre du
groupe de mix et c'est son devoir aussi
puisque elle veut peser ce sol dans le
concert des nations
et aujourd'hui ça lui l'autre fois je me
faisais la réflexion et je pensais
lorsque nicolas sarkozy était présent de
la république qu'il y avait eu des
conflits en géorgie il n'avait pas
hésité à se déplacer
pourquoi emmanuel m'apprend navire est
il pas un ancien premier ministre et un
ancien ministre des affaires étrangères
une personne eu un ancien président de
la république pour pour pour faire en
sorte que les nations européennes à
l'image de l'autriche qui a pris une
résolution par exemple est bien seul hic
pour dire stop aux exactions turque ce
stop aux menaces turcs parce que s'il ya
une chose qu'on peut pas reprocher à
monsieur erdogan sait ne pas annoncer la
couleur
et malheureusement il sait ce qu'il dit
merci c'est qui est vraiment dramatique
en amont japon pour l'europe laisse
faire merci beaucoup
valérie boyer d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
sénatrice les républicains des bouches
du rhône s